Hallo Leute! In unserem heutigen Video
möchte ich mit euch darüber sprechen, wie man im Deutschen Sätze verneint.
Tatsächlich gibt es im Deutschen zwei Methoden, eine Aussage zu verneinen.
Man kann "nicht" benutzen und man kann "kein" benutzen.
Und in diesem Video erklären wir euch, wann man was benutzt
und wie man diese Sätze formuliert. Los gehts!
Der grundlegende Unterschied ist eigentlich einfach:
"Kein" benutzt man immer dann, wenn man ein Nomen verneint,
und zwar ein Nomen mit einem unbestimmten Artikel oder keinem Artikel.
"Nicht" benutzt man in allen anderen Fällen. Hier seht ihr zwei Beispiele:
Ich bin nicht dumm. Ich bin kein dummer Mensch.
Schauen wir uns den ersten Satz an. Janusz hat gesagt: "Ich bin nicht dumm".
Ohne Verneinung heißt dieser Satz "Ich bin dumm." In diesem Satz gibt es ein Verb und ein Adjektiv.
Man benutzt daher zur Verneinung ein "nicht". Und dieses "nicht" stellt man hier direkt hinter
das konjugierte Verb. Ich bin nicht dumm.
Ich bin nicht dumm. Ich bin kein dummer Mensch.
Schauen wir uns den zweiten Satz an. Ohne Verneinung heißt dieser Satz:
"Ich bin ein dummer Mensch". In diesem Satz gibt es auch ein Verb,
auch ein Adjektiv. Aber es gibt auch ein Nomen und dieses Nomen hat einen unbestimmten Artikel.
"Ein" dummer Mensch. Und deshalb benutzt
man hier "kein" zur Verneinung. Ich bin "kein" dummer Mensch.
Theoretisch könnte man auch sagen: "Ich bin nicht ein dummer Mensch."
Das könnte man zum Beispiel sagen, wenn man speziell das Verb betonen will,
zum Beispiel als Antwort. Jemand hat gesagt: "Du bist ein dummer Mensch"
und ich sage: "Ich bin nicht ein dummer Mensch" Aber eigentlich ist sowas extrem ungewöhnlich
und es klingt auch komisch im Deutschen. Deshalb merkt euch unbedingt:
Immer wenn es ein Nomen gibt mit einem unbestimmten Artikel,
benutzt man "kein". Hier gibt es noch ein paar Beispielsätze:
Also 'n Ausländer is klar, 'n Ausländer ist jemand, der kein Bürger
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland is. Das is 'n Ausländer.
Und ich bin, auch wenn ich in England bin, bin ich der Ausländer.
Aber für mich ist das keine Beleidigung, sondern einfach nur 'ne Definierung
von jemandem, der nicht von hier is sozusagen. Und davon hängt das ab, also ich mein',
für mich is das klar. Ein Ausländer ist jemand der
kein Deutscher ist, so einfach is das. Sind Sie der Meinung, dass ma...
dass es in Deutschland auch so'n sozialen Druck gibt zu
trinken mit den Freunden? Ja, gibts auf jeden
Fall. Also das ist jetzt kein Druck, das ist einfach gesellschaftlich so verankert,
denk ich mal schon, ja bestimmt. Was ist, die die perfekte
Menge am (an) Alkohol an einem Abend? Ähm, kein Alkohol.
Schauen wir uns den letzten Satz nochmal genauer an.
Janusz hat gefragt: "Was ist die perfekte Menge Alkohol?"
und der Mann hat geantwortet: "Kein Alkohol" Im Englischen ist die Satzkonstruktion
hier sehr ähnlich oder die Übersetzung
sehr ähnlich. "kein Alkohol" = "no alcohol". Sobald wir jedoch einen vollständigen Satz haben,
sieht man den Unterschied im Englischen und Deutschen sehr deutlich.
Ich trinke nicht. Ich trinke keinen Alkohol.
Wenn ich im Englischen sage: "I don't drink." dann würde ich auf Deutsch sagen,
"Ich trinke nicht." Ich verneine das Verb.
Wenn ich im Englischen jedoch sage: "I don't drink alcohol.",
es kommt also dieses Objekt hinzu, dann verändert sich im Deutschen die Satzstruktur.
Im Englischen sagt man immer noch: "I don't drink alcohol." Im
Deutschen sagt man jetzt: "Ich trinke keinen Alkohol."
Etwas anders ist es, wenn man über eine bestimmte Person
oder ein bestimmtes Objekt spricht. Wenn ich sage: "Ich trinke kein Bier",
dann heißt das allgemein: "Ich trinke nie Bier." Wenn ich jedoch Bier trinke, aber dieses eine
Bier nicht trinken möchte, dann sag ich im Deutschen:
Ah, ich trinke dieses Bier nicht, es sieht komisch aus.
Hier sind noch zwei weitere Beispiele: Wer ist das? Ich kenne den Mann nicht.
Wessen Jacke ist das? Mir gehört diese Jacke nicht.
Wir können uns also merken: immer wenn wir ein unbestimmtes Nomen verneinen
oder ein Nomen ohne Artikel verneinen, dann benutzen wir "kein".
In allen anderen Fällen benutzen wir "nicht". Und dieses "nicht" und dessen Satzkonstruktion,
gucken wir uns jetzt genauer an. Wie sagt man das auf Deutsch? Also,
nein, ich bin nicht verkatert. Nein. Der Mann sagt: "Nein, ich bin nicht verkatert!"
Hier sehen wir das "nicht" in einem regulären Hauptsatz.
"Ich bin nicht verkatert." Das "nicht" steht also
direkt hinter dem konjugierten Verb. Hier noch ein paar weitere Beispiele.
Ich trinke nicht. Ich kann nicht singen.
Ich bin nicht verkatert. Als Nächstes schauen wir uns einen
Hauptsatz mit einem Objekt an. Aber würdest du auch sagen,
dass du Deutscher bist? Äh, Nein. Also nein, weil ich hab'
hier meine Kindheit nich verbracht. Ich spreche die Sprache sehr gut,
aber nicht muttersprachlich, ja? Janusz sagt: "Ich habe hier meine
Kindheit nicht verbracht." Sobald es ein Objekt gibt,
ändert sich die Satzstellung manchmal leicht, dann steht das "nicht" meistens hinter dem Objekt.
"Ich habe hier meine Kindheit nicht verbracht." Interessant wird es übrigens bei Adverben.
Wie ihr wisst, sind deutsche Satzstellungen manchmal flexibel und
vor allem Adverben können an ganz unterschiedlichen Stellen im Satz stehen.
Und so kann auch das "nicht" vor oder nach einem Adverb stehen
und manchmal ändert sich dadurch sogar die Satzaussage leicht,
wie in diesem Beispiel. Ich gehe heute nicht einkaufen.
Ich gehe nicht heute einkaufen. Beide Sätze, die Janusz gesagt hat,
sind richtig grammatikalisch. Im ersten Satz sagt Janusz:
"Ich gehe heute nicht einkaufen",
das ist eine allgemeine Verneinung, er geht heute nicht einkaufen.
Vielleicht geht er morgen, aber das spielt hier überhaupt keine Rolle,
denn er verneint das "einkaufen gehen" an sich. Im zweiten Satz
ist das leicht anders, dort sieht man das "nicht" vor dem "heute".
"ich gehe nicht heute einkaufen". Damit betont man das "heute".
Und wenn das "nicht" direkt vor dem Adverb steht, dann wird also
dieses Adverb betont und speziell verneint. Janusz sagt damit, ich gehe nicht heute einkaufen,
aber ich gehe wahrscheinlich an einem anderen Tag einkaufen.
Das würde man zum Beispiel sagen, wenn man sagen möchte,
ich gehe morgen einkaufen. Ich gehe nicht heute
einkaufen, ich gehe erst morgen. Als letztes schauen wir uns noch Nebensätze an,
hier ein Beispiel mit Janusz: Ich fühle mich gesund, weil ich nicht rauche.
Janusz sagt: "Ich fühle mich gesund, weil ich nicht rauche."
Wie ihr wahrscheinlich wisst, ist die Satzstellung in einem Nebensatz
etwas anders als in einem Hauptsatz. In einem Nebensatz steht das konjugierte
Verb immer am Ende des Satzes und das "nicht" steht meistens
direkt vor dem konjugierten Verb. "...,weil ich nicht rauche."
Man kann die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft bekommen. Dazu gibt es Tests, die gar nich' einfach sind.
Ich hab mir das mal angekuckt. Die Fragen könnte ich nicht
ohne weiteres beantworten. In diesem Beispiel gibt es sogar
noch ein Adjektiv vor dem "nicht". "...die gar nicht einfach sind."
Die Frau beschreibt die Tests zur Einbürgerung in Deutschland
und sie möchte sagen, dass dieser Test nicht einfach ist.
Es wird also das Adjektiv betont und diesem Fall kann das "nicht"
auch vor dem Adjektiv stehen. "...die nicht einfach sind."
Ja das war jetzt gar nicht so einfach. Wir haben tatsächlich noch nicht alle Fälle
der deutschen Satzstellung erörtert, das ist vielleicht nochmal
ein Thema für ein anderes Video, aber wir hoffen, ihr konntet schon mal verstehen,
wann man "kein" und wann man "nicht" benutzt. Und das solltet ihr jetzt auch
unbedingt weiter üben und das könnt ihr auch zum
Beispiel mit unseren interaktiven Übungen. Wie ihr vielleicht wisst, haben wir eine
Mitgliedschaft bei "Easy German", ihr könnt ein Mitglied werden
über Patreon und alle unsere Mitglieder bekommen jede Woche interaktive Übungen,
die meine Schwester Isi für euch vorbereitet. Und bei den Übungen,
zu den Übungen, gibt es auch ein Forum wo man sich austauschen kann.
Wenn ihr Lust habt "kein" und "nicht" weiter zu üben,
dann werdet doch ein Mitglied, für nur einen Dollar pro Woche
seid ihr schon dabei und damit unterstützt ihr auch unsere Arbeit
und damit helft ihr uns, dass wir mit "Easy German"
immer weiter machen können. Vielen Dank für's Zusehen und bis bald!